on va faire une interview première voir
ses prêts premier disque que tu as
acheté premier disque the piper at the
gates of dawn fouet puis damien sépare
et non je suis un fou je mets ces
ambiances comme centre et si tu vois
c'est mon premier disque après premier
film canadien times le projet chine
cuisine vous ces bons changements
ouais j'ai pleuré toute la marque et la
maison blanche contre le premier fleurs
premiers flirts besoin ni d'une vieille
de 16 ans or copine de ma soeur ma soeur
en retard donc moi produit tant la
situation et il ya un passage en caisse
capelle premiers pas cette affaire je
crois que c'est une 13ème
c'est très surprenant parce qu'on touche
plus de pain qui laisse à mes copains de
classe message chèque de 40 bars en
supermarché c'est à lillehammer est
maintenant finalisé un autre coup pour
au moins trois ou quatre premières
idoles les premières idoles bien avant
de regarder je crois que c'est françoise
en fait première idole c'est ça et les
10 de pressignac d'amérique femme et son
époux première clé une première cuite 15
en angleterre quand j'allais travailler
dans les hôtels est vraiment la mort de
très près quand la tête dans la cuvette
des chiottes toute la nuit à la bière je
me suis dit que je n'en ai plus jamais à
une première fois que ça fait la loi qui
fait 12 ans et demi à peine abete a
raison et demie masekela talent oui tout
va commencer par tous ouais bah oui eric
un garçon disons regard sur dix ans un
copain de classe qui ne joue à la maison
après l'école et c'est pas ce qui s'est
passé dans les cantons se déshabiller à
une résistance qui courait je me suis
mis sur lui alors le truc hâtivement
désespérant rien ne se passe
donc on s'est rhabillé mon article on a
continué à jouer ensemble en a jamais
reparlé
j'aimerais moi oui oui ça décolle de
traîneaux mladin c'est pareil pour
connaître ses premiers succès premier
succès me disent que moukandjo robbie
williams
oui disent attendre les succès
professionnels des premiers succès
professionnel mon premier disque quand
même sympa marche au niveau vance que
c'était génial dans le voit en vitrine à
van noten la barbe blanche et non
ennemis l'exemple de la rue et par les
arènes et tu veux regarder toute la
journée
j'étais très déçu en face côté un
centime ne met plus prochain son premier
million premier million un souvenir que
j'affectionne particulièrement
j'étais en 85 avec pompey pour la france
les chronos nation qui on est tombés
pour la france ça a changé et carrément
la ville est à la fête
j'ai acheté une chaîne stéréo ce que
j'avais un pick-up encore c'était
carrément les être présente au niveau du
mal tu es une fille est une chaîne
c'est le site et c'était extraordinaire
de pouvoir un peu d'argent devant soi
parce qu'on habitait dans un taudis en
neuvième on avait vraiment va crever la
dalle laissé branché que je fais pas les
de dormir c'est vrai c'est pas des
souvenirs malheureux premier cancer
premier concert
les transmusicales à rennes 20 minutes
le hockey pendant 20 minutes avec
certains musiciens marc ysaye des
copains sur les coeurs c'était bien un
bon souvenir ce premier échec
professionnel
chez ces derniers ne sont pas vraiment
des ailes vraiment des déchets itunes
veut très sûr le beau père travaille
premier devant c'est plus un échec
personnel que chaque personnel en
personnel 22 ans
il s'en sert si mal et le choc sensoriel
son premier million de nouveaux francs
il ya trois ans heureusement là ça quand
je le veux bien faire du mal au projet
puisque j'ai acheté un appartement pour
la mère donc je vous vendre quelques
disques première télé aux premières
télés fr pro à rennes une réalisation
brillantissime maxime utile et un fou
rire
bien qu a duré qu elle voit une forme de
chanson pacifiste et lundi pendant 3 min
et la dernière volonté ça sera quoi
ma dernière volonté d'être incinéré
dispersé
elle a une façon très grande fête